hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly video game chat show right
here on videogames.com or twitch.tv
forward slash gamespot or in your ear
holes if you're listening to this on the
go on your itunes machine your podcast
streamer your friggin
god knows what you don't know that we
have this sick boat in the background if
you're doing that so maybe tune into the
video version isn't that right eric tay
yeah man that boat is sick the ssg is
that what you call it i call it that
i've been calling the ss pikmin yeah
that makes sense because of the pikmin
captain what would you call it casting
vote michael maherty the
ss
snizz i don't know what it's rocket
league lingo
that's it that's his lingo
top right corner goalie couldn't chew it
so his problem is he he keeps calling
this rocket league like word terminology
but really this is just lacrosse
[ __ ] right yeah it's more
just me
making things up i guess did that
speaking of lacrosse and video games
yeah has that review gone up yet rarely
do those worlds collide but yeah it's up
five out of ten for casey paul lacrosse
16.
casey powell i'm sorry who is casey
powell it's like tiger woods yeah we
know who that is madden yeah casey
powell famous three brothers casey ryan
and mikey powell who went to syracuse
university they're really good players
uh so my alum or no my alma mater i'm an
alum i mix that up but yeah uh no it's
the best lacrosse game ever made
five out of ten good huh the worst as
well uh no it's just there's not much to
compare it to there has been another
lacrosse game oh yeah um there's one
that was uh crowdfunded by the iroquois
tribes up where i'm from like central
new york they kind of you know jesus i
know nothing about lacrosse the uruguay
tribe
use an example for like native american
tribes iroquois
county that there's like onoda tribe
yeah onondaga
wait is the cross native american yeah
okay so i know it's american sport yeah
they used to play it like over that
field to settle disputes and like weed
out the men from the boys and stuff okay
i feel like it could be violent if if
i'm on something i know
if i'm surprised it's because i've only
ever seen like
a very
tall white men playing oh yeah that's
all i've seen that's
that's what's funny about it but there
it is what was what was that what did
you give the the lead what was it
oh what's the lead yeah like what's the
lead the written lead in the story yeah
what is the serious lack of flow
pete pete encouraged me to uh use
lacrosse dialect okay
oh man i wish i became like an esport
you would be the best commentator for
that that would be really fun oh well
thank you so much mike for coming on
today's show uh
that will that wraps up our lacrosse
coverage this week so if you're here for
that you can you can get right out we
have a bunch of stuff to talk about
though we're gonna talk about paragon in
a second uh big conversations about the
division since it's been out for a week
youtube been playing for a week um i was
out of the country so i only got to play
for uh yesterday the day before i just
want to catch up on that at gdc of
course again developers conference is on
only two blocks from here in moscone
center uh the awards are on the choice
awards on the igf awards around tomorrow
so we'll go through uh some of those
nominations with peter brown uh as well
as talking about pokken pokken
tournament which got nine out of ten
review up on gamespot right now
but first of all gentlemen
let's have a little chat about paragon
which is a game that
exactly that little shrug you made
that's what i would say every time
someone said paragon to me it sort of
existed in that in that coin chris
waters that melange of moba
overwatch battleborn battle cry it was
all kind of in there together uh but the
i guess the
closed alpha it's still closed at the
moment so i think they're opening it up
later in spring we got access to it a
couple of days ago
and i've been playing a lot of it and
i'm actually kind of super into it for
somebody who's never really been into
moments but who loves games like unreal
tournament so i want to kind of ask you
guys
about this as well because we've all
kind of played it i know you've played a
bit of it today or yeah and mike how
much have you played well um i played a
few hours probably around eight total um
i did the preview event for it a couple
weeks ago and then i played a little bit
once we had the access and uh yeah i
like it it's it's definitely like
starts from like
uh epic's action roots yeah like the
third person action you know like which
they're known for and uh yeah it
translates really well it's definitely a
moba more even more than like battleborn
has that one incursion mode which we
also have access to now but we haven't
been able to get any matches um
but this is very much like a moba but in
third person like very action focused it
is a it is one map there are three lanes
there are towers that you knock down
there is a core you need to explode and
it's 5v5 as well
and it has some element of shop in it as
well in the card packs it's got a jungle
which in this case is a forest which you
were saying has most of its textures
have yet to grow yeah it says like alpha
it's in alpha the so don't worry about
the mobs you know they're they're gonna
look better probably you know they're
just kind of shells of what you would
fight in a jungle but yeah it it as all
intensive purposes is a traditional you
know moba yeah except for third person i
guess so except for third person and i
guess also the thing that is different
between this and most mobile games is
that most moba games isometrically
you're most of your targets are getting
locked on so you're like attacking
people and then basically triggering
attacks like you would in you know
the root of those games games like
warcraft or one or games like diablo or
whatever whereas this game you're
basically shooting like you would in any
other third person shooter so it feels
like like it actually kind of feels like
when you were playing
third person parts of unreal tournament
like the way it controls like maybe
you're in vehicles and stuff it like
feels super familiar that way um maybe
in the modern ones uh but yeah apart
from that it's essentially mobile you're
shooting creep and you're upgrading your
person and uh
yeah
so it's this weird kind of
yeah it's like it feels super familiar
at the moment you start playing it even
though you've probably never played
something exactly like this before yeah
i mean a lot of the skills kind of
translate you know
it's kind of hard to
expand on the world of moba and skills
right so a lot of things are very
familiar i think i played gideon his
ultimate is pretty much if anyone's
played dota 2 it's kind of like you know
enigma's black hole right like it just
sucks everything in and it's supposed to
be like something there for like what i
like to say the wombo combo so that you
know your teammates can come in and like
do other abilities and you chain off of
that so it's cool i mean the action's
fine i don't know if it was just gideon
for me that felt a little slow i know
that his shift mechanic let him kind of
like speed up a little bit but you don't
use that in combat that's kind of like
your mechanic to kind of get back and
forth a little bit faster outside of
like teleporting to your base yeah it's
weird so you you hold down shift well
there's nothing new about holding the
shift to run you holding shift to like
engage travel mode and i guess the the
sort of the negative part of that is
that if you get caught if you give
somebody like
uh catches you on the way in and hits
you while you're in travel mode you get
stuck for like a couple of seconds right
and they can just like pound on you for
a while yeah cause if you come out of it
manually it's pretty fast if you
actually like um i
just started figuring out if i just
activated one of my i had a leap power i
like mayhem he's which traditionally i
don't really like tank characters but
for whatever reason this kind of game i
do uh he has a leaping attack and i
would just press that and it would
immediately get me out of the travel
mode and give me an extra like 30 feet
so it's kind of a good combo but yeah if
you date someone else interrupts it then
you're kind of like screwed for two
seconds or so and that's what's cool
about this in terms of because
mobas are games of inches right it's
like how it's understanding the range of
your opponent understanding the range of
your attacks and how best you can do it
and what i've really enjoyed about this
is that like the battles i've been
having like against melee people um or
maybe i'm like a
dude with like two pistols right he's
like shooting people he's pretty one of
the good starter characters and he has
this sort of one of his power-ups that
you can upgrade is like a leap uh which
can
give you like you know 10 feet on the
other person and i've been playing these
people who've been like using melee like
swings at me and just barely missing me
and i'm like jumping out of the way like
like by you know it's like skimming me
and then everyone starts seeing me cool
down on this little
leap attack turning around using it to
get away and then just like pounding on
them yeah it's like it's and it's fun it
like it feels like oh that's what i see
when i see people play like really you
know good level dota or lol but this is
actually in a game that i would play
like i like okay so perspective shooters
and third person shooters that was kind
of where i was headed next i guess
because mobas are kind of a thing that
you know they were on the rise right and
then they kind of plateaued a little bit
because there's just three heavy hitters
that you can't really get by you know
and then now
you know smite probably the first one to
be kind of successful in like a third
person mode so it's interesting to hear
that you're actually more willing to
play a game like paragon knowing that
it's a moba because maybe it just has
unreal roots or something yeah like
because i went back and like i never
really played much smite and i went back
um over the past couple days to like
watch a bunch of smite again to see like
first of all that game like i think it
only came out like two years ago i think
it was like april 2014. well maybe that
was like the final version but it just
it looks it looks super aged yeah in a
way that like the feedback this game
first of all looks good but also the
feedback you get on when you're hitting
people is like you know you need you
know you need that in games like this
you need to be able to be like okay like
in the division you feel the numbers
coming off them you know when you're a
tax land and you know and you get that
like really good feedback from the game
and this game has that really well which
i enjoy about it so i was like
encouraged to go around and try
different
here i don't know what they're calling
to call them heroes or whatnot
and you can because of that feedback
visually or audio or whatever it is
you also like for instance looking at
the
the gameplay here of the various other
attacks in the game you kind of pick up
on what exactly all that stuff is doing
really quickly whereas watching all the
smite footage i was like oh yeah i get
like if you put the timing you figure it
out but like it wasn't that immediate
thing and when you're talking about a
game with all of these heroes and all of
these different ways of playing that
stuff can get super intimidating like
with overwatch like that's another game
that sells it really well this game
doesn't have that many heroes though it
feels like it looks like 12 or 15 or
something i wouldn't be shocked if
there's going to be like more though
right like this alpha
you know you can always build you can
always have more right like that's how
you just get people to keep buying
characters
during the preview event i had i had
asked and epic said they plan on doing a
lot of post release stuff which is which
suits this the nature of these games
well and that's the thing like it all
these games like you had said that
melange it's kind of actually i was i'm
about as lukewarm as you can be when it
comes to like battleborn overwatch i was
having fun with everything and then
paragon but and i wouldn't say i'm like
extremely excited about any of them but
they i am coming around to the idea and
like coming around to the fact that oh
these games all just kind of add that
that reflexive like quick reaction thing
to the overall strategy which i like
strategy and i like shooters those are
both like two of my main backgrounds
like i kind of just starting to realize
the potential of combining those
especially when we can talk more about
battleborn i'm looking forward to that i
can't speak to the overall quality of
battleborn but it does do some like
interesting things and then overwatch is
doing its own thing paragon is doing its
own thing and i'm actually kind of
looking forward to seeing all the
different like i don't know permutations
that can come out of combining these
genres i'm coming around to it really
fast but it's exciting it's like the
difference between dole and lal right if
you're not in that like area and playing
those games like who cares like
you wouldn't really give a [ __ ] and i
feel like these games maybe
it's just personal but like i feel like
me and a lot of other people they were
all just kind we didn't really know that
much about them we hadn't played them
and it's like oh they're all kind of
doing the same thing whereas now yeah
they all completely they're completely
different piece like overwatch i love
for loads of different reasons like it
feels more like counter-strike to me
obviously this is nothing like that game
even though i was pulling them in
together yeah and the same kind of thing
i think my
i don't know expectation means a lot and
my expectation of paragon wasn't too
high it's like that's free to play
third person moba thing it's coming out
this year but i'd encourage people to
play it yeah like i was like i played a
game which lasted 40 minutes and went
straight in and played another one and
like that doesn't happen with me and
mobas so yeah yeah definitely
recommended the playstation 4 pc
is what the current alpha is in there
doing some sort of paid alpha apparently
yeah you can so i was trying it last
night right i
don't quote me on the date because i i
think that's right i haven't slept very
well a lot since but uh i think it's 3
18 if you buy it you get into the
founders pack and i think the cheapest
one is twenty dollars so i think you'll
have access in like a couple days if you
uh if you just at least spend the twenty
or or what not but what's that money go
on
uh what is it because the game's free to
play and it's out in the summertime i'm
sure i didn't again i didn't look at all
the details yeah but i'm sure it's like
a card pack thing or maybe like a skin
pack because there are like you can see
that there's like a drop down for like
do you want to pick normal gideon or you
know your normal hero or like a
variation of your hero so i wouldn't be
shocked if it's skin related or maybe a
card pack thing um something that
hopefully doesn't alter the like
gameplay like not a pay-to-win thing but
a cosmetic thing yeah so i mean yeah i
couldn't
hopefully they know that that is not
what you do with these games yeah the
balance would just be
trash if they did that right yeah
totally do you have any previews up on
the slide about program yeah there's one
just about how like epic's passed with
action games has influenced it um it was
about a week or two ago
some some headline like that i don't
remember exactly yeah i had a pretty
positive experience with it sweet if you
want to learn more about paragon
go to gamespot.com look up that thing
that mike just
told you bad google it i don't know do
the work we haven't figured out a way of
sending video links yet so just do it
yourself and let us know if you're
interested in paragon if you're not in
paragon if you want to check out the
beta ps4 or pc let us know in the
comments below very interesting thing is
happening gentlemen right now on twitch
chat which is that also right now there
are some news coming out of gdc about
sony's playstation vr okay previously
known about as the morpheus the problem
is
that you can never tell if the chat is
telling the truth or not there's all
this [ __ ] flying around i'm like looking
you can see me probably all the time
just like checking in the corner it's
being like yeah and someone's like
saying oh yeah 399 dollars yeah and it's
coming out
can we just check the twitter sixteenth
of october well yeah we were waiting for
something right
yeah especially today apparently today
apparently sometime i think they're
having a press conference down the road
like they're not live streaming i don't
think i think it's just like they're
having it and then the embargo
drops and then we'll know stuff whether
we know the price
yep 3.99 eric yep i just got on the
twitters but thank you mary very much
voice of god mary cage 400 bucks and
what was it october 2016
october cool called it sweet 400 bucks i
mean called it i thought good money was
on 400. yeah yeah i knew it
i knew it they had to go lower to try to
you know compete that's how i felt at
least october baby right ready for
christmas that's like yeah
although
it's it would be what like seven though
huh because you have to count the
console if you don't own one on the
console mm-hmm man if you buy a console
buy a [ __ ] oculus rift yeah no
we're all about the vive now right at
least right now
because we have the vibe in this room
we're getting our
don't talk to me
i don't want to buy a samsung phone
buy the s7 you'll get a free uh you'll
get a free one all right so okay
who here owns the playstation for all
three of us okay 400 bucks eric tay will
you buy a playstation vr no not at least
uh not right away i think
i think with this kind of technology i'm
gonna do the wait and see approach right
and kind of gauge you know which one i
like the best what has the best
application software games what not and
you know luckily fortunately for us we
do have ways to try that stuff out so
that will give me an advantage of like
okay i want to you know do that or i
don't want to do that so
that's what i'm going to do i don't know
what about you mike uh if you'd asked me
six months ago i would have said
probably not
it took me forever to get on the vr
train but then since then i've gone to a
bunch of events i've played a bunch of
games like shoot
full-on 400 sounds sounds fine i'll do
it yeah i'm excited i feel like it's
been a while since i bought a ps4 so it
doesn't feel like it's that much of a
yeah you know it was like a couple years
ago so it's not too crazy
one of the things i'm really happy about
what's happening and you notice a lot of
something like gdc is that
like making video games is super
dangerous because the install base of
any one of these is really low but
everyone's spreading the risk it seems
like everything that's coming out on
playstation vr is also coming out and
oculus is also coming in on vive and
obviously there are some stuff isn't but
like you can kind of bet on most of the
stuff coming out so that's kind of
exciting because that means that stuff's
been coming out for oculus already like
last year with people with the headsets
loads of stuff's going to come out for
that this year the pre-orders for the
vive that means they'll be in people's
hands way before this comes out as well
which means by the time playstation vr
hits store shelves or whoever they're
going to sell this um
hopefully there will be actually quite a
lot of software available for it at
launch and it'll just be this like
horrible connect situation you know
where there's like three things to use
it for i wonder if the 400 includes
like i actually have still have about
four playstation movie controllers at
home and i wonder if they've thrown
those bundle or something yeah because
all the other ones have to have their
brand new controllers you know like
the uh
they they have their own names but
obviously you know the circular ones
that wrap around your hand with oculus
and then the actual sticks with the vive
yeah there you go there's the specs
thanks so much mary it's a oled display
5.7 inches 1080
um
120 megahertz so is that split across
both then i wonder does that make it 60
what's 60 anyway i imagine uh
field of view approximately 100 degrees
latency less than 18 milliseconds thing
that says controller dual shock 4
and playstation move so it doesn't say
if it comes with it no it doesn't i mean
standing in front of a big screen oculus
doesn't come with the controllers
it does not vibe does for 800 oculus
doesn't for 600. yeah it comes with an
xbox one controller comes with an xbox
one pad for some reason god known
forsaken yeah who knows wired xbox one
pad as well i think i think yeah yeah so
there you go i wonder how many i wonder
what the final version has for usb i
will have plenty of stuff open game spot
anyway just i wonder how many usb ports
that i think takes because the original
because the ps i think the playstation
vr has a breakout box on it oh okay so
like the box plugs into
so i mean that's scented nitty gritty
but that'll be interesting i wonder 400
bucks like that seems
any cheaper and you're like why am i
buying this maybe is it just a piece of
crap like 400 sounds like okay it's
gonna cost a lot of money oh here we go
final contents of the pack
does not include a playstation move
controller it's got a breakout box got
the headset
yeah all right that's all the
information is there last note on this
actually is a bit of a tangent
how does that i like how that it feels
on my head it's actually like lighter
than the other ones it i haven't played
it for so long but i've had it on for
like 30 minutes so they go one stage and
i felt good mike what do you think about
it playstation viewer playstation is
comfortable um i think they're all
pretty comfortable relatively i think
the one that i have had most trouble
with and again it's not much is the the
oculus because i it's just i think it
does feel slightly heavier but it's also
just maybe i haven't been like gotten
used to it as much but yeah playstation
was comfortable from the i've spent the
least amount of time with that one but i
remember coming away from psx saying
that felt really good right yeah because
we had it on quite a lot then as well
yeah what about yourself eric more or
less the same i didn't have it on for
that long either i only had tried like
one game i think a psx as well so it was
just fine felt fine didn't make me like
like oh my god my head you know and
getting tight or something it was fine
cool all right well there you go that
happened just now uh all right let us
know
whether you'll buy it i guess 400 does
that feel like a decent price for you if
anyone's actually in the comments who
has just bought a playstation like in
the past 12 months how does this feel to
you as well uh yeah what games are you
looking forward to on playstation for vr
as well let us know in the comments
below all right gentlemen we've got
another thing to get on to here very
quickly
shifting from the world of playstation
to the world of microsoft they announced
a couple days ago that i guess while you
were
cross-platform multiplayer i guess is
the best way to play to describe it xbox
one games playing not only with
windows 10 games which is not all that
new in the world of video game
multiplayer but also opening the doors
for xbox games to play with playstation
games um
i was about psionics if i say cygnosis
wrong video game company sonics have
come out and said that this is great
that they're going to try and implement
this into rocket league which is great
because already that was a playstation 4
game that could play with repeat with
the pc fan base and vice versa and the
xbox one guys were sort of left on their
own uh
where do you think this comes from mike
the in
i guess the reasoning behind microsoft
doing this is this just another shaking
off more
you know leftovers from the previous
regime or
does this actually work for games like
the division for instance where there
are people about to buy this game and
maybe the install base is lower on the
xbox one and they want they don't want
to discourage people from playing on
that i think in terms of software sales
it's not going to hurt anyone you know
you have games like titanfall where
people are really liking it or evolve
which is you know i think was a good
game but then the multiplayer base drops
off really fast so now
you know ideally you'll have three
different platforms to just really
bolster a multiplayer base and i can
only imagine it's going to help the
developers making games and it's going
to help you know the players like never
like have a shortage you know because
multiplayer bases i don't know people
realize it's really hard to maintain
like not many games keep one for longer
than a few weeks after launch a huge one
and uh i can only imagine this will help
um from a business standpoint i
i think it's i don't know like the
actual like how the numbers shake out i
think it's a good move on place uh
sony's part to like in sorry microsoft's
parts like invite sony into this because
you know like you said with games like
rocket league uh it works really well if
they could just figure it out like how
to do it across three different
platforms and the best case scenario i
think it's a good move yeah i mean it
makes business sense right more than
anything else yeah i think so i mean
it's definitely going to open up more
just a bigger install base as you said
right so that more people can play with
other people you know it's like the
dream right like i want to play with my
friend
in destiny or something that plays on
xbox one that i can't do because we're
on separate consoles and we don't want
to re-level a character to play with
each other because that's just a huge
waste of time how many times have you
bought a game on a specific platform
because of your mates like i feel like i
do that all the time yeah like the
division was when i was like i want to
get on on pc but everyone's playing it
on playstation 4 and then i was like
i'll just buy it on pc i guess and
rocket league is not a perfect example
of this where you know the xbox one
version obviously has a bunch of cool
cars that aren't on the other ones and
maybe halo fans want to play that but
then they're like um well maybe i'll
just get it on playstation because all
my buddies are playing on that or pc and
that seems like to me kind of the
hardest part of this from a business
perspective in terms of so there's a lot
of this exclusivity now right or like
one month early access to
you know content right
how do you
open this up for like i mean obviously
it's not all the games right away
in in a perfect world yesterday but
how do you do something where you know
like let's say the division is getting
xbox one dlc first right like how does
does the playstation people just not
they're not able to play with the xbox
one people in that content yeah only
then or like the destiny had guns that
you know uh and on ps4 that xbox one
didn't have so like oh that guy's got a
hawk moon and we don't even have that
in our game i mean i wonder yeah because
like because then presumably the
playstation 4 version of rocket league
would need to have the warthog in it
to display the warthog because like even
if you can't bite yourself i mean i can
see the batman car even though i've not
bought that dlc pack but you know
because then you're into like weird
licensing issues where okay now
microsoft's gonna license out the look
of the warthog
on a sony console yeah you know where
that problem wasn't there before so yeah
i wonder i mean i mean it's opened the
door whether or not you know people take
advantage of us
and master the hero and the twist chat
said end of the console war
if anything this like shows that
the concert was alive and well microsoft
are like benny yeah right i think the
console wars will go on definitely like
indefinitely as long as there are like
console specific games too right like
it's like oh yeah i because from their
perspective it's like oh yeah i got ps4
and i have this game and you don't
that's why ps4 is superior because it
also looks better
anyways
but you know what i mean like the war is
alive because of you eric today i know
that's what i'm there
yeah the console war is like oh yeah i
don't jump on it and because of a tomb
raider just a little bit maybe forza you
know
andy bauman's not here anymore we don't
have to talk about forza shout out to my
man
he's gonna crash through the wall
now he's not gonna talk about forza yeah
he works for ubisoft he talks about the
division now no no company man
no he talks about uh what's the
the crew
that's the only driving game
oh wow okay all right
there you go yeah i guess cross-platform
open uh the last point on this sonic
said uh we're thrilled to confirm the
rocket league will be one of the first
games to take advantage of this new
capability by enabling cross network
play is what they're calling us between
xbox one and pc players with an open
invitation for other networks to
participate as well sorry that was sony
who said that an open invitation to
android
to ios and sony as well i guess
so yeah so there you go let us know if
you're excited about this in the
comments as well in the twitch chat do
you have a situation is there like one
game where you and your buddies play
that you wish you had cross platform
play cross network play that maybe this
will open up uh let us know in the
comments below
gentlemen
it's time to talk about smallpox
oh god you ready it's so dark
i had to ask you what the division's
disease was before we went alive because
i completely forgot i'm pretty sure
that's what it is i think it's a small
part it's some variation or like you
know they made some weird disease i'm
pretty sure it's kind of what happened
there and they engineered something yeah
that's what happened right black friday
disease yeah greed probably some acronym
for it h1z1 and h1 that's a video game
that's a real h1n1
and that's the bird flu right yes
swine for blue oh bird i don't know i
get my flu's mixed yeah the one that'll
like murder you yeah i it's swine flu
it's pretty it's not that bad just do it
flu right yeah it's not even yeah it was
more like hedge i was i felt like i was
off my face for bed two days but i
wasn't like getting sick running it was
just like oh two days off work it was
great i called up nhs direct which is
like the uk is like when you're sick you
call them thing and they're like stay at
home
like
what like should i go to the hospital
they're like no i don't go to a hospital
because you'll infect everyone there
stay at home if it gets really bad let
us know right all right so it's out of
home paid video games for 24 hours mark
your house and like all right there's a
guy
in that house that has if anything
happens we know it's because of that guy
yeah exactly you just draw like a pig
snout on your front door and then you're
done anyway
let's talk about the division
sweet came out last week yeah i wasn't
here
no you all made a bunch of videos about
it great job thanks that game looks okay
yeah depending on which version you're
it's it's actually
pretty amazing if you if you've looked
at the three versions like xbox one is
probably about like easily by far the
worst and it's not good
rabbit hole i can see the youtube thumbs
downs just in already
so i want to talk to you about a bunch
of stuff obviously we we talked about it
on for a lot last week but there's two
kind of things i want to talk about
we'll talk about the pvp stuff in a
little bit sure but first of all i want
to float this idea with a bunch of
people who work here in the office who
haven't played destiny for
ever since it came out every expansion
pack we we go back in and we sort of
talk about it and we've posed a lot of
like is x game better than destiny's
stuff all the time sure and it gets
really trite and why not but i genuinely
want to ask a question about if the
division has sort of like in its launch
and in the type of gameplay it has if
it's like learned from sort of some of
destiny's shortcomings
because this is a game that i've been
playing only for about two days i wasn't
really into the alpha very much but i'm
really enjoying this game the game i
think maybe the difficulty balance for
the alpha was a set a little bit too
easy or something and i wasn't finding
it challenging but for whatever reason
i'm really enjoying this game
solo in a way i never played destiny so
i want to pose this to you guys you play
a lot of destiny right yeah like i know
eric you obviously know about destiny as
well so
have you had this experience at all that
like you're enjoying this game more or
less or it's it's providing you more of
a
i don't know interesting palette of
world to play in and does that even
matter to you
so if we're gonna compare it to like
destiny and my experience like vice
versa or whatever um
once you hit the end game it's very
different from early right early to
middle because i was playing early to
middle with rob and or solo and it was
fun because you know you're doing story
you're doing campaign and um that
stuff's better than what launch destiny
was but when you hit end game and you
start having to you know grind out the
dark zone or do really hard missions
that you can't do solo i really miss
like all my destiny friends i'm playing
on xbox one right now i you know i don't
know as many people on xbox one i did
that because i know that the dlc is
coming out sooner and so it'll be better
for content for us and i don't want to
level again on ps4 so that cross play
stuff might actually be good however
uh just getting to the end game i'm just
like man i really this sucks playing
solo like i don't want to do this any
like really anymore uh it's more
motivating when you're playing with a
group
even if it's not your friends
necessarily to you know you communicate
you're like okay
it's such a huge thing because that's
what the skills are for you know like
i'm gonna use my ultimate now or like
i'm gonna put pulse up or all right
let's use the marker in five it's gonna
count down five seconds all right we're
gonna hit that target all the same time
you know like there's that communication
when you're playing kind of by yourself
it's like uh and the matchmaking yeah
it's albeit it's good because you can
match make with other people but you
don't get that same camaraderie you
don't get the communication and then it
just like falls apart and for me that
experience at least end game isn't as
fun i guess but then again i had a group
in destiny so who knows i might not have
if i was playing by myself in destiny
who knows i might have fell off that's
like that's literally the reason why i
stopped playing it was because i just
didn't find it fun as a single-player
game and i've not played that much of
the division i you know i've heard that
it gets more challenging and that you
really want to squad up later on but
from what i've been playing so far i've
been like doing hard missions and and
really enjoying it
let's speak a little bit about the world
because i feel like that's another
aspect that i wasn't so much into with
destiny that obviously the story got
stripped out of it we realized you know
six months later that it had been
completely pulled out and they basically
like rejigged the game together and
that's why it felt so you know
uncohesive or whatever um the division
the story you can sort of take or leave
i think feel but like the world itself
the detail in the world the world
they've built all those little like
flashback things you can sort of dive
into
it feels like there's a a lot there to
explore have you been enjoying that at
all mike yeah that's the main draw for
me there uh maybe it's just because you
know destiny's sci-fi it's not something
i can relate to immediately but like i
know like pete and alexa are both from
around new york as well right and
i was playing with jake and justin last
weekend and i pulled up the map and i
was like where are we right now it's
like oh we're on like 34th and 9th i was
like i lived like
three blocks from here obviously it's
not a one to one scale and it's not
going to look the same but it was still
really cool because it did feel like new
york and then you go through the village
and the christmas lights are still up
and there are all these like little
stories you see in the world that
there's it's there's not a lot of
exposition with those ones but it's
still there for you to find if you're
looking for it and that goes a long way
to help me in most games you know like
the witcher does a great job of it you
know the elder scrolls games do a good
job of that but that's what's really
pushing me forward here and it i really
really just i love how
the tone of it and just how it's it
feels like really lonely the city at the
same time but but at the same time
you're playing with other people and
you're kind of just going through these
alleyways like again not necessarily
that the same as what i've experienced
but
it's really alluring on just that like
environmental like tonal sense and i'm
i'm really enjoying that aspect for sure
yeah i've done a lot of like wandering
off the beaten path recently or i just
said i just pick a part on the map and
kind of go over there and see what i run
into and i mean most of the side quests
they're pretty repetitive it's a lot
like they're all the same yeah similar
and whatnot but there's still something
about it i don't know just like
wandering around and seeing like life
just kind of happening that you wouldn't
have noticed you might not have ever
seen you might not have ever gone over
there um that i'm really enjoying again
maybe i just haven't played enough of it
you're not getting tired of this whole
snowy
the same though you're getting sick of
the snow it's just this like all the
like yeah some of the buildings are
different but just in terms of like
running around the world everything kind
of looks similar other than the day
night cycle which kind of like tricks
you a little bit in in terms of like
what you see but i don't know i'm kind
of over the division world as it is what
do you think about the
the upgrade loop that they've put in
because in a way it's common well i
guess it's not similar in that way to
destiny but destiny had a sort of hub
little area that you go back to a lot um
obviously in the division that
takes place as you also your upgrade
tree i guess um how have you been
enjoying that aspect of like upgrading
the very is that basically the crux of
the game as you're playing as like
upgrading your your base and clearing
out all those missions i mean upgrading
the base is definitely important in the
long run because
unlocking certain buildings will give
you a lot of good talents a lot of good
perks especially the thousand uh dollar
one because that one gives you your
ultimate skill which is like really
clutch it i mean it's cool to see how
the headquarters change changes as well
when you kind of upgrade it all the way
i wouldn't say it's what the end game is
that's just part of the end game the
real end game is just min maxing your
gear
and that's really it it's like a loot
it's like a loot chase really it's more
almost like diablo right than anything
else like there's so many kind of
similar mechanics like you're just
farming for loot you're trying to
upgrade your loot you're trying to crash
like you're trying to yeah rolling the
dice for loot in that sort of ware radio
kind of way yeah but like destiny like
you had the raid right and the raid was
kind of like the end game thing that you
did to try to acquire that loot there
isn't i mean
the division they're like you still do
dark zone and you kind of get that stuff
but there isn't like really that tier of
um
the thing i gameplay striving and
getting all my gear for to then do
something harder to get the best gear in
the game right now it's just you're
trying to make the best game gear in the
game almost or hope that it drops which
is like weird don't you get someone
later in the division that kind of
functions like uh godola the enchantress
in diablo yeah so she uh that you get a
recalibrating station in uh in the
headquarters after you upgrade a tech
wing and that lets you kind of roll
stats on your gear some like really min
max cater to the build you're going to
make you can make like a full support
build and have like nothing but
electronics or you can try to go super
tanky and go all stamina and that that
station again
you can get that earlier it's just like
kind of not worth it till like later
later parts of the game because you
don't really need to min max as much
until later in the game like i feel at
least i would say spend more time
playing the game than doing that stuff
because you're going to replace that
stuff you know what i mean it's there
for when you hit or get close to 30 and
you're like okay this backpack's really
good but this stat really sucks but i
could change that one thing and you're
like okay i'm gonna change that one
thing so that's kind of like those are
the rpg type mechanics and i i find that
cool that's like the coolest thing for
me but to do all that stuff you need to
have like credits and
materials and that's the stuff you have
to grab wait no and the fork 67 says
greenwich isn't in the game mike
oh it's not apparently that's not where
the christmas lights are all right but
there's christmas lights somewhere else
there you go yeah game delay says i'm
loving the story npc's both main
friendlies and major enemies seem like
real people this is the weirdest thing
about this game is that they kind of do
seem like real people and i feel like
this like government [ __ ] who's
literally murdering people for looting
it's like
like i'm kind of like
i think i was more critical of that when
i played the elephant i was like oh this
game's not as realistic as like i would
hope when i see the words tom goddamn
clancy put on a game like as somebody
who loves like rainbow six and ghost
recon and even advanced warfighter like
had an element of realism but now i
don't really care but it is funny that
you're like you're i was iron is making
a good point you find somebody who's
like losing a dead body
right so they you didn't even see them
kill that person yeah and you go up
there and you [ __ ] ice them and then
you loot their bodies
there's like there's no morality
they're rioters okay nanny riders the
vision agents need to
tear these people out they're bad people
these cleaners these riders these rikers
we got to get rid of them they got good
luck hey look the rikers are like
ex-cons right yeah that's true and then
there's dudes who are going over [ __ ]
flamethrowers like they need to go but
just like poor people and hoodies i keep
murdering what i think are just lower
class new yorkers like that's with this
guy like this
cleaning out the lower east side
basically yeah yeah which you know which
isn't in indianapolis video games they
see you they point the gun what are you
gonna do you're gonna let them shoot you
no right well also another weird
disconnect is when you rescue hostages
you unlock the door and you go in yeah
and then you find like three shotguns in
the room you're like are you really
hostages at that point you couldn't
organize some sort of poo or or when you
give uh energy bar or
or soda to a civilian in need and
they're like oh here have a pistol like
that so you didn't need this pistol to
survive this post-apocalyptic world you
just needed a soda oh my favorite part
is they don't even give it to you they
just drop it on the ground
there you go you got to pick that up
yeah pick that up there's a pistol
it's crazy so it's the only difference
between civilians and the bad guys in
this game is that they have their hoods
down
because everyone's got at least like a
parka on uh well the cleaners have like
masks and stuff right and uh well yeah
just a regular gen pop 99 hoodlums yeah
i guess regular people they have some
type of headgear yeah that's fair so
just some kid in a slipknot hoodie he's
just gonna get iced because he's
it's cold out and he's like
so uh we were talking in uh some sort of
history class way back in the day and uh
my teachers there's a reason the world
banded together to get rid of this and
then apparently it would just if you
were lying in a bed your skin would
become so covered in like pus and boils
that it would like mesh with the sheets
so when you roll over
it'll just like
tear off
so that's why smallpox was such a huge
deal like you did not want it so don't
go out on black friday don't worry stay
away from new york just yeah just err on
the side of caution who knows ubisoft
might do some viral marketing
champagne which might go wrong next year
expansion oh my goodness
moving on
i want to talk about another aspect of
the division uh the pvp right so i've i
did a little bit of dark zone stuff in
the i guess the closed beta i haven't
done any yet
since i've been playing solo on my own
obviously that's kind of what's all
that's left after you've finished the
main campaign uh
apparently it's like super imbalanced at
the moment
it's not so much that the fighting is
imbalanced and some would argue that the
like you can argue that the dark zone is
a pvp area it's like you don't have to
but you can but what it really is is
that
going rogue is supposed to like for most
people that want to go rogue is a very
fun thing to do so going rogue is that
like if you shoot another like
non-hostile agent
yes exactly and you're like
you want to either take the risk of
killing him because he has loot and
you're like i hope he has good loot or
he's just a jerk face because he killed
your boss
yeah he or she is a jerk face but you go
rogue
it's like you lose so much experience
when you die as a rogue that it could be
30 minutes 45 minutes an hour plus of
work that you just did that it's so
not worth it to go rogue
that just don't go rogue because the
risk reward is just totally scary and so
and that essentially just kills the
whatever pvp element there is because
most people are like well i'm not gonna
do that because i just lost all this
time doing it and on top of that there's
people that are starting to play like
games and shenanigans where they try to
get you to go rogue so i'll tell you
i'll tell you i'll tell you this
story last week i'm soloing the dark
zone grinding my levels and i happen to
run into three other players that are
clearly grouped up and we're kind of
clearing out an outpost or i start
shooting at like an area and i just see
one guy he's just kind of like
serpentine right next to me near me i'm
like dude what are you doing right and
then i'm starting to think oh you know
what he's trying to do
i'm pretty sure he's trying to run in
the line of my fire and get me to go
rogue and so friends with him yeah and
so i'm like all right
that's not happening and i run away and
they chase me around for like five
minutes i'm running circles and i'm
literally looping and they're just
bullying me and i was like this is the
worst feeling ever
but on this at the same time like a day
later yeah it actually happened where i
was shooting and then somebody just
jumped her jumped in front of me
on purpose
or on purpose i go rogue
they murk me and i lose 30 000
experience which is like one level when
you're in the 40 plus range and that one
level soloing probably took me an hour
to an hour and a half so i lost an hour
to an hour and a half i didn't even care
about losing the money any loot i cared
more about the experience because you
need to try to hit level 50 dark zone uh
like as another pre like another
requisite in the game end game to buy
other stuff and so i was trying really
hard to get there and these jerks did it
to me twice and once you're not the only
person in limac in the twitch shot you
would have seen on the screen there as
well a very similar story somebody
walked into your line of fire
intentionally to make you go rogue so
they can kill you that really sucks
that's kind of ingenious as well yeah
how would you how like from ubisoft
standpoint how would you even like nerf
that i mean they've been they changed so
much of the dark zone during the alpha
right like during the beta i remember
they they changed the frequency by which
you saw npcs went up the difficulty went
they're still doing stuff now they're
still tweaking this again yeah so i
guess they're just gonna
but you're right like how do you stop
people yeah doing the exploit like
do you have to shoot your shooting more
than one no like i don't know well there
are what can not make it worth their
while yeah i guess or something i don't
know what some people are doing though
instead that the people that actually
enjoy going rogue and want to have fun
going rogue because they're like okay
i'm gonna set my main character aside
and make an alternate character
and then i'll use my alternate smurf
character to rogue and pvp people
because i don't care like i'm not afraid
to lose anything but anyone that's
trying to play end game or like high-end
content and wants to farm and stuff like
that they will not
like ever it's just a waste of time so
are you done in
dark zone until they fix this or are you
no i mean you still do the dark zone
because
personally no because i still i still
have to go in there to get gear to get
some materials to craft other stuff and
like i said for the most part since most
people don't go rogue you're basically
running around friendly like the whole
time everyone is just hive mind of like
oh we're just grinding we're pbeing
together like whatever i'm not gonna go
rogue on you like most people i would
say right now 70 to 80 of the population
if not more are just grinding it like
you would a normal mmo like not trying
to kill each other okay and then there's
like 10 15 jerk guys that want to mess
with you or something like that and
that's a good ratio that's not too bad
it should be higher though it should you
should be able to like that that was the
kind of cool part of what people thought
the dark zone was going to be and that's
one of those
yeah you can have a lot of fun doing
that
and people did but then once they
realized how much they were losing
they're like whoa look
i'm good like i'm not doing that again
because
that's too much time wasted right
there's an interesting social
engineering class there it's like you
make it just not worth people's while to
people to do illegal activity and they
won't they won't do it and that's the
pvp in the division a review up on
gamespot right now it's eight out of ten
yeah it got on the site
available on a bunch of platforms except
the wii u sorry it's probably coming
probably for the best it's not going
yeah you got wii u play
how was your how was your how's your
uplay experience going on this game have
you unlocked all the we
would you play points i have unlocked a
lot i think and level is your you play
man
character no no
so okay so the funniest thing is
going into playing the division right
rob and aaron had played you know like
far cry or maybe yeah so they had a
bunch of you play points like hey crew
yeah maybe the crew and they're like hey
eric you can uh take those bucks and
unlock all these cool things before the
division comes out you can already free
uh mod skin you can no in-game stuff
ringtones you get uh this weird looking
i was rocking this was it the sports bow
or something there's like this kind of
jerk like varsity jacket hat it's like a
fake knicks thing or something yeah
yeah exactly someone called me like i
was the dad from you know the 70s or 80s
or whatever everywhere in my old miami
yeah that stuff laces out
laces out i'm in crazy time claire walsh
wants it laces out okay
but yeah uh there you go okay i take it
back you play came forward i guess
i came through after all these years
play to get stuff i guess i mean as long
as it doesn't really influence the game
i mean there's only a couple of things
that you can buy from that that actually
go like oh that's kind of like in-game
currency let's not do too much most of
it it's like crazy it's like med kits or
cosmetics even most of the the a lot or
a lot of the things you pick up the um
clothes and whatnot are just cosmetic as
well so yeah it's kind of cool all right
thank you both gentlemen for coming in
and talking about le division available
on your video game platform of choice
right now go check it out all right
let's get peter brannon here he's
probably waiting that side for like 20
minutes so sorry peter mike maherty
thank you so much for joining us thanks
for having me later man thank you for
your ace ventura quotes take your cup of
cha away peter brown how many ace
ventura pet detective quotes did you
bring with you today to class why don't
you cry about it saddle bags
and mice
that's very good thank you that's pretty
good what's up
that movie's probably old right probably
i'm trying to think how old that movie
is let's look it up 90s okay let's do it
okay no price is right it's closest
closest to it yeah can i just do one
dollar bob
um
let's see if i was 84.
come on 97 okay
95. 94.
we're old you won then i just didn't
think i was 10 when i watched that
that's right i was 10. i watched a v for
vendetta on the flight
back from ireland
that movie came out in 2005.
movies 11 years old that's a good movie
though it says okay but it's actually a
bit more hokier than i remember yeah
yeah it's maybe not as great as i
remember but it's it's okay didn't stand
the test of time no but it's actually
closer to what britain is in 2016 so
maybe maybe in the future it'll be more
accurate we'll have to find out
how you doing peter i'm good man you did
a great job here last week on hosting
the lobby i did a job you did a great
job yeah great man it was fun it was fun
i enjoyed it uh thank you so much for
coming on doing it uh we're not here to
talk about last week we're here to talk
about the future the future of video
games and what better way to talk about
the future of video games than giving
games from the past awards uh the game
developer conference choice awards are
on this wednesday night uh they go hand
in hand with the igf awards the
independent game festival awards which
will also be giving it a bunch of prizes
two video game creators from video game
freighters for video refrigerators and
refrigerators and i thought it'd be fun
to go through a bunch of the
nominees and tell them which ones they
should give okay how about that game of
the year either 404 the witcher 3
metallica solid 5 bloodborne or rocket
league that's very close to mars
yeah yeah
well i know what he's picking we're just
going to have our debate here all over
yeah
rocket look should be won
you know like i i felt at odds with
rocket league being so high until i
actually started singing time into it
right now i feel totally happy that we
gave that number two yeah like totally
deserved it
that said i would still put metal gear
above it
cool fair play what about you tay i
should have pushed harder for bloodborne
even though i there was no way we got
fourth it got fourth okay i felt like i
could have pushed it past rocket league
and then i could have pushed your metal
gear to like two i don't know you know
what sounds like that it was yeah only
myself and matt espinelli have actually
finished metal gear in this office right
and everyone who talks to me about that
game is so ill-equipped to actually have
a conversation yeah
but i'm the same way when it comes to
the witcher right yeah i haven't
finished with your three and it's and it
kills me last year was a real son of a
[ __ ] for trying to complete those games
because like fallout 4 was thrown in
there as well so yeah it was mental yeah
it'll be interesting to see i mean i i
think they'll probably give it i don't
know i feel like they might give it to
the witcher 3 yeah like i'd go for the
widget three but i feel like
i won yeah i don't know because this is
like a game designers
yeah it's different so it's so different
they go for it but then maybe they give
it to kajima then because it's like
that's well you want to imagine they're
not doing it because of the cultural
like right yeah surrounding it but that
game had a lot of crazy things put into
it that worked really well so
we'll find out i guess let's jump into a
couple more of these innovation awards
uh her story super mario maker undertale
splatoon the beginner's guide
this is an interesting one for
innovation because i feel like undertale
is an old game done differently mario
maker's
a mario game her story i remember
hearing afterwards that they basically
made a very similar game a couple of
years earlier a few different people and
i probably should look into this myself
before claiming anything on the air but
the word is is that uh her story uh you
know it came after a few other games the
same creator used very similar tricks uh
within the narrative so it might not be
as innovative perhaps not oh yeah we
should look into well here we
splatoon which is uh that that's
innovative in in many ways uh and the
beginner's guide which
is sort of innovative interesting
loads of different ways i'm not sure i
call it innovative necessarily but there
you go i would give it to mario maker
yeah yeah i think it's the first game
that really made like creation the the
number one thing and then like game play
was number two but even then game play
is like still so great in that game it's
it's kind of hard to match and but
creation and making communities out of
it is something that hasn't really that
i mean maybe in pc world that that
happens with things like counter strike
and team fortress but right but mario
maker it opens the doors for like really
crazy things and it is still going
strong and nintendo is still adding
things to it i know that's not all
innovation but the same way they
definitely found a thing that worked
yeah they struck gold with that no one's
ever done it before they go dead
eat it best visual art or in the blind
forest the witcher 3 star wars
battlefront
splatoon
um i would give it to bloodborne
personally it's called born or ori yeah
yeah or
beautiful or he's a great looking game
yeah yeah very pretty bloodborne yeah
that
battlefront's that game the best part of
that game is how it looks and sounds
yeah and it's also in audio along with
oriental blind forest everybody's gone
to the rapture mega saw the five
encrypted the necker dancer i love that
that's in there that's great
uh any takers on that one
i'm not going to go to bat for metal
gear
there is one thing in that game that
does audio that i love so much
quiet humming in your ear stop it
yeah the the effect of having your
partner hum in your ear and having this
really subtle companionship that's sort
of like
it
yeah man it becomes real and you don't
even realize it's like the subconscious
thing that you develop and when it's not
there you're like wait a minute wait
wait something's missing what is that
and then you realize what it happened
the whole time that's awesome uh i guess
the last one we'll look at here on the
gdc awards best narrative her story the
witcher 3 life is strange undertale the
beginner's guide again
sounds to me like the witcher
witcher for me as well i think probably
yeah but then i've not completed life is
strange so i can't wait to say but there
you go congratulations to all the
winners that we just named
congratulations exactly let's hope they
get them right at the awards show
congratulations to all the nominees but
while we're here let's have a look at
the 2016 independent game festival
finalists this is always very
interesting because i remember for years
you wouldn't know any of these games
yeah and then you kind of know a couple
of them and now i feel like i know most
of them every year when they come out
like the sheamus mcnally grand prize is
between darkest dungeon her story keep
talking and nobody explodes mini metro
super hot and undertale all games that
i've played a decent amount of yeah so
i don't know what would you go for the
grand prize
that's tough because the games are so
different yeah darkest dungeon in her
story yeah well bomb defuse okay bomb
defusal game and
mini metro like mini metro's so good is
it that's the the
one where you're like you're basically
making a it's like a london tube map of
what it looks like or like a subway map
and you're basically just lining things
up it sounds great
it's like a really basic version of
factorio
that's really good keep talking and
nobody explodes it's really interesting
the way it integrates just the physical
with the virtual like i would that was
the first one i wanted to say so yeah
i'm gonna go with that i saw on reddit
as well that it sold 200 000 units i
believe it yeah that's really incredible
yeah look at this what a great game like
it okay maybe it doesn't look too great
look at this thing right here
absolutely exhilarating
for those on the podcast version there
are two gentlemen with beards sitting
across me each other at a coffee table
one of which is reading a book uh but
yeah it's super fun it's on oculus but
obviously you can just play it on a
normal ass pc as well yeah and like you
think you can like cooperate with people
like i would be trying to do like so it
looks like a horn i'm like what kind of
horn you know like i don't know it's
just a horn like it's
it creates arguments when there
shouldn't be because like a horn like
the instrument or like yeah
but it instills like really good tension
and it's just really exciting it's fun
to play with people like who don't play
games yeah
any sort of aptitude
uh excellent in visual art this is where
we get into a little bit of obscure
games uh armarello darkest tundran mini
metro oxenfree
uh
panoramical and
g-nog
i don't know what g-nog is panoramical i
believe is that very trippy looking game
and i wonder how much of that is
orchestrated versus generated right if
you understand what i'm saying
yeah that'll be interesting can we give
can we give no man's sky some props for
all the beautiful graphics when it's
just made up by an algorithm it's all
pastels no no art no no uh no artist
behind it is it really art nouveau
awards
uh this is actually i'm not gonna go
into that one pronunciation novo
amarillo amarillo i want to give shout
outs to these games uh sibel which sybil
sybil i think it's sabell sabell oh god
we suck at our jobs uh fantastic
contraption her story keep talking
nobody explodes
orchids to dusk panoramical progress and
the beginner's guide uh i believe that
section sort of highlights games that
are doing something new and interesting
mostly so i think people should check
out those games we just listed out just
for the sake of like looking at what's
out there because that's one of the most
interesting parts of this award and also
to that point best student game ape out
be glitched chambara hopefully not only
circuit infinity orchids to dusk and
pitfall planet all games oh my god
what's happening here hello here's a
video game there's nina freeman of
course
that is nina's game i saw her outside
the office bought
two hours ago uh and then excellence in
design let's do this for the last one
her story infinite factory keep talking
no explodes kingdom mini metro and super
hot super hot
i might go keep talking again
super hot yeah
there is a lot of the same games on all
of those there is
i'm just saying i wouldn't be surprised
if someone goes home a multi award
winner that's what happened with
what was this we had two years ago we
were backstage and
you had the name i asked you this
earlier it was the game you papers
please god yeah papers please oh yeah
guys
you guys played a crap ton at gamescom
right like you got totally into it
that's great it's a great video game
great video game anyway so there you go
congratulations to all the nominees for
the gdc and igf awards best of luck
tomorrow
and i hope what we said wins because
it'll make us feel good
in our bellies uh let us know what you
think should we in the comments below
we're almost done for today's show i
just got here man you did we talked a
whole bunch about the division before
you came here good because i don't know
anything
what have you been playing this week uh
shadow complex remastered oh cool that
game is so much fun i can't talk too
much about it even though it's been out
forever
is that embargo there's a review embargo
right anyway it's um it's still a great
game
have they changed much about us no and
that's actually one of the cool things
about it it just looks better
i mean honestly it doesn't even look
that much better
it's
it's just i can play it again it's it's
weird
i'm debating whether or not i even
review it because honestly uh our old
review written by lark anderson who
works in our product and engineering
team he kind of captures exactly what it
is and uh and that is a game with
relentless pacing and uh and great
action there it is
look at this relentless pacing look at
all those great actions complex shadows
so many of them hunt all the complex
shadows uh cool all right we'll look
forward to that review hitting the site
real soon another review
that hit the site real soon
a wonderful game by the name of pokken
tournament has just got a nine out of
ten on gamespot.com did i pronounce that
one right peter brown yes you said that
as though i chastise you
been poking me about my
pronunciation do i no you know you sit
so far away my arm i can't that's true
i i'm just transitioning back from
ireland mode as well so i'm saying all
my words wrong one two three uh pokemon
tournament nine out of ten tomorrow
who's saying reviewed it tour you're
saying it's first review for us oh
really i know it seems crazy because
he's a really smart dude yeah he's been
around for for a good while too nine out
of ten it's a
fighting game it is a fighting it is a
3d fighting game it is a 3d slash 2d
fighting game okay so in the like tekken
and what not uh
tekken is 3d um so in the middle of a
battle if you do a certain amount of
damage or you perform a certain move it
goes from this sort of 3d all-range mode
to a 2d plane or pokemon or fighting
sort of similar to street fighter move
back and forth then you can break out of
that again and go back to the field
phase
so you've been playing a bunch of this
as well you obviously didn't review it
for us i have played a bunch i'm not
currently playing it anymore um there's
a lot going on but the game is really
fun when i sat down there for the first
time i had sort of looked at it as one
of those naruto fighting games um
because it kind of just resembled it
like on a really general like broad
level um
but
one it's a little bit different because
it has those two phases but also as
someone who who's liked pokemon over the
years and continues to kind of like it
but my appreciation's been waning maybe
a little bit this was like okay wow i
actually have control over pokemon
directly and as tomorrow points out like
you're interacting with these pokemon in
real time like against each other it
actually feels like you would imagine a
pokemon battle would be because
it's
what i mean yeah we like collecting
pokemon and i guess fighting in them is
kind of fun but really there's you know
saying like pikachu
do a lightning bolt like that's not that
fun to actually just like do the
lightning bolt as pikachu right and then
keep going and keep fighting and not
waiting your turn so uh
that many other reasons the game's
really good are there still humans
shouting orders at you no
not anymore no so you're just doing yolo
you're just like whatever i'm a pokemon
i'm free yeah you don't feed me puffins
anymore
is that what they were
what
you know what a puffin is right yeah
like a miniature penguin yeah i'm just
misinterpreting a
very funny youtube video from a couple
years ago
he also mentioned in his review lots of
like
mode variety which is somebody who
bought street fighter 5 and has been
rather frustrated
lack of mode variety thank you uh yeah
that sounds interesting to me so is
there loads of different ways to play
this game multiplayer and single player
is loads fair i don't know if lows is
fair i mean you've got there's
definitely some and i know the story or
whatnot league is you sort of just like
climb a la it's like climbing a tower in
mortal kombat right you know that that
kind of thing is shank zone at the top
yeah okay yeah it's goro no is he not
pokemon it could be a pokemon no uh
doesn't like what is it much
um yeah i mean honestly there aren't
that many modes but there's at least the
most you would expect let's put it that
way yeah ultra ajari says in the twitch
shot how many pokemons are there in
pokken 16. got to catch them all it's a
lot easier 16 17 if you get mute shadow
me to you and then that's like your core
set right and then you still have your
assist
uh pokemon as well so that's an assist
pokemon uh jigdy puff yeah you sort of
like there's a meter that recharges and
you can call them in and they do an
attack that either like will hurt the
enemy or impair them in some way like
jake the puff dude yeah put him asleep
well jigglypuff's not there damash
there's also an annoying heel that randy
was using on me a lot what was that well
one of the assists heals you so he'll
gain his life back like man he's like
you could have that too eric i'm like
yeah i could but one of the criticisms i
have about pokken is the the roster
selection which like
forget about how they look like whatever
they all play fine but when i'm looking
at the list it's like there's a
chandelier pokemon as one of the main
fighters like there are 721 pokemon at
this point surely there are ones better
suited than a freaking chandelier one
man
how did chandelier never come up in all
like the the many what's the dumbest
pokemon segments we have done on the
lobby because there are 721 pokemon
there's goro there's goro fighting right
there yeah that's my champ hey man
chandelier pokemon i don't know his name
sadly but it's probably chandelier or
something he needed a time this was one
of those times you know he's going to
get a time to shine now you're going to
remember him for the rest of your life
yeah
they said that there's no plans for dlc
right now but i'm calling bs on that
because
i mean what a gold mine this is going to
be for them if ever there was a game
right for dlc oh there you go it's a
chandelier pokemon
for those of you on the podcast feel
free to google chandelier pokemon and
i'm sure this is the first one that'll
pop up it kind of looks like vanilla as
well
stroke the chandelier pokemon
um
i will say i will say the game's like
supe super accessible yeah uh like
anyone can play it and like have fun but
it's it seems like it can get pretty
deep too because you know there's
counter attacks kind of like a focused
attack and street fighter it's gonna be
at evo so you know there's that it's
gonna be an evo like legit or they're
doing it paid for no it's one of the is
it ten games this year it's one of these
seven hundred games
there's not there's seven
it's like it's a double digit it's like
double digit but it's going to be there
high level high level pokken tournament
i mean you know there is room for like
if there's high level smash play i'd say
it's fair to to say that there could be
high level poke and play right it's just
like the barrier to like perform a
certain move is much easier than
something like street fighter because
it's just a direction and a button right
like two buttons yeah tamora said it was
kind of easy um like a good sort of
quick one to get into people don't play
fighting games
and love them pokemons
gotta gotta love them all okay catch you
gotta buy the pillow
case can you get pikachu like pillows
like love that you know sleeping pillows
like i know it's just like a wifey
pillow yeah
so if there was like chloroform in there
you could just sort of like oh it's
perfect
like a tiny speaker that the battery
kind of slowly went on so i was like
that'd be really good you can have that
for free pokemon company is that what
it's called yeah someone's on it right
now hey we just heard a great idea uh
the glitcher 1705 said this is not
directly related to pokemon okay do you
have any info of when htc vive will be
on the gdc or valve's the lab game
i had to ask i'd love to answer that
question asked this question about seven
thousand times in the chat there you go
okay this is five of them the lab i
don't know have you seen the lab yet the
lab
i think that's a
that sounds familiar i'm not sure what
it is though i'm so i'm still confused
uh hassan has put in all the games that
are evo this year street fighter 5 super
mario bros you count them all right
street fighter 5 super mario bros super
mario bros super mario super smash smash
yeah super mario coming to evo where are
you going to fight goombas yeah
sorry again street fighter 5 super mario
street fighter v
super smash bros
melee
yeah so super strong there's two
versions super smash bros for wii u
yeah there's melee and wii u so that's
two so that's three that's three total
now guilty gear
revelatory revelation or revelator or
whatever mortal kombat x yep going to
give it to you
pokken tournament
ki yeah ultimate
m versus uh marvel vs capcom three yep
umbc and tekken seven
fate nine ninths almost all the figures
where's that double digit
mr wizard that'll be the last thing you
put in there
mr wizard is that a he helps us run eva
lacrosse tournament it was also a show
that i watched as a youth where this old
man would give science projects to
little kids mr wizard yeah and if they
screwed up he would like
he would like talk [ __ ] to them on here
right like let me show you how to do it
just stupid kid there's great videos on
youtube i'm getting angry kids that was
mr wizard
yeah you know what could be tenth but
they're definitely not going to do it
and people actually wanted it was ultra
street fighter 4. oh right but they're
not they're definitely not doing that
just because capcom would not want that
no you want to move to the next yeah you
got to move to the next platform man you
got to get pushed that can we talk about
the sales of street fighter 5 real quick
sure 200 000 worldwide oh god they
wanted 2 million by march yeah yeah
that's really bad wow i was looking at
the
steam
what's called again i don't know the
steam stats thing i always look oh
whatever it's called it's like the one
that like tracks all this and the pc
sales were not that great those first
two weeks it's bad super street fighter
4 an update to the existing games sold
more in its first few weeks wow than
this new street fighter 5 did man you
just don't want to launch a game broken
anymore or launch a game without like
it's weird i wonder i honestly think it
was the climate surrounding the game
like when it came out i just feel like
people were still okay with street
fighter 4 when four came out we didn't
have anything like it for years and five
shows up and it's sort of like yeah like
superficially right from the outside
looking in it's like i don't really know
what i'm getting that's any different
yeah just looks like yeah 3d street
fighter and a 2d plane okay i get it
well also with street fighter 5 i
remember a while back ago they're like
oh yeah five's not coming out for a
while like 2017 and i was like oh
surprise
boom uh no it was right after they
started they they did that merge with
sony or they got that kind of like that
deal that was it was announced
right yeah that was when they kind of
made the push up like oh yeah this is
happening a lot sooner then when is the
big march update coming for that by the
end of the month okay right yeah the end
of march end of the month
might be the big april update we'll see
how i'm so concerned have you seen how
they're going to try and combat rage
quitters
oh by having people publicly shame them
they're like recording them on a one by
one basis yeah they need people to like
say when it happens they're going to go
back and review like the tape
and then like get rid of their like yeah
what a way to make people feel
comfortable
settling up to your game you know like
can you blame like a 13 year old kid who
like like doesn't want to lose and signs
off it's not like we're all grown adults
playing stuff and we need to be shamed
like that kid's going to feel bad and
he's probably not going to want to play
anymore if capcom publicly calls him out
no that's how you teach him a lesson to
you that's how you teach that's why you
don't rage quit that's how you're kids
yeah you don't rage quit it's fair you
sit there and you're gonna put like
photos of your kids on the fridge every
time they rage quitting games
like think about it like smoke that
whole pack now let's let's use like an
analogy right like do you hate
sorry they're showing mr wizard the
b-roll has suddenly shifted gears to mr
uh for the podcast listeners this is a
uh gentleman who seems to be cooking
some sort of
pink egg
in front of a gormless child who doesn't
know the slightest thing about
thermodynamics you really need the audio
because kids say things that he's like
no
you idiot
if you listen to what i just said
mr wizard was before oh the internet he
was before the internet which was his
time yeah this show was the best casting
tana i was going to say though
like think about i mean i don't know if
you would publicly shame them but let's
say you're playing a game rocket league
right like let's say i go four i'm down
4-1 with about two and a half to three
minutes left yep andy bauman was
infamous for wanting to forfeit right
away which is the essentially a rage
quit right yeah without closing your
application i'm like no we're not doing
that yet
even if he thinks that they're better
than us but the other team would get the
points is the thing is that rage
quitting you don't win either do you
know yeah you just get nothing it just
kind of like kicks you out a lot but
that's beside the point it's the
principle yeah you don't do that that's
why you gotta get changed should
publisher slash developer be calling
people out i don't know let us know what
you think
in the comments below all right that's
the show for this week it's the longest
lobby since we got back really aaron 12
minutes
talking about video games uh what's
happening at gdc with you guys uh first
of all peter brown i'm gonna go see uh
mizuguchi talk about perez sweet because
we all love rez right did it bring that
suit back
uh so right now in japan they have this
gigantic display called
might even just be the res infinite
experience i've seen this they're
demoing it like to the public yeah which
is just amazing like when this game came
out on the dreamcast in 2001 i think
like no one really knew much about it
like i knew my friends knew kind of but
but here it is now it's like sony's like
vr flagship experience for people who
just want to get a taste right and
they're demoing it at like this like
really like big glass window and some oh
it's held so you can see over there
it's crazy that's pretty cool yeah
excellent uh i want you to you're
helping me yeah i'm helping you with
these hot sessions um and then also one
of those days i'll be out but mary will
be back there and i'm going to i think
see
king's quest uh i think chapter three i
believe and then i think the new
tmnt which could be cool you know dude
platinum yeah yeah of course yeah i
liked i like transformers i mean like it
didn't
last but what i played of it and the
nostalgia and all that stuff which is
probably what ninja turtles is going to
do for me too
um is going to be awesome i think yeah
and actually at the show inauba of
platinum uh is giving a talk about them
sort of taking on these projects and
giving platinum games to like the
mainstream audience yeah versus like all
their really hyper-focused like
hardcore stuff yeah it's pretty cool
interesting hopefully it'll come out
real good and yeah we have a this is the
lobby for this week we have a bunch of
sort of special lobbies lined up and
we're calling them the gdc sessions
we're basically getting in developers
just going to chat to them like this for
an hour or so
there's a couple of possibility ones
actually i'm going to check right now
i might feel like people keep shuffling
around so we've got some big names that
might be coming in there yeah don't
promise something no we're trying to
squeeze them in the actual confirmed
ones we definitely have uh marcin
owinski from cd projekt's going to be
sorry cedar project is coming in can't
say cd projekt in front of them to talk
about i guess how they feel about the
witcher 3. uh adam salsman's coming in
uh matt lees and kelley fallon's got to
come in on friday and talk about some
interesting press aspects uh i've also
got the creator of frog fractions
coming in see
mr jim crawford is going to come in i
don't think he's going to reveal frank
factions too
well then why why is he even coming
to talk about stuff let's talk about
mystery actually he had a really good
gdc panel that a couple years ago i went
to ever sort of retaining mystery in
video games and how like difficult it is
in the internet age so maybe we'll talk
a little bit about that i mean the
ultimate way to keep mystery is to not
tell anyone when your game is coming out
yeah or what it even is which is what
he's doing because he's crazy
so that should be fun it may never even
come out it may have come out already
yeah right never mind it will never oh
it never comes out yeah it's the
ultimate kickstarter campaign the
ultimate long con
peter brown thank you so much for coming
in any time eric tay pleasure as ever
always a pleasure thanks so much to mary
kish in the back for directing the whole
show
dan mchork as ever for keeping all the
cables running we'll be back next week
tuesday 2 p.m pacific as ever uh the gdc
uh lobby sessions will not be live but
they will be going up in full on
gamespot.com and
youtube.comspot and they will also be in
this audio feed as well so you'll see a
bunch more
on coming up on your itunes whatever
your podcast platform is of choice over
the next coming days thank you so much
for hanging out we will see you next
week and during the week as we report on
gdc
talk to you later bye
you